thank God I'm missing the Playoffs so I
could focus on Research oh you down and
out unsure what's riding to the playoffs
at Chargers Auto Group our bandwagon is
huge and this bad boy is very empty it's
all electric and it comes in dope colors
not sure about budget we're flexible
exceeding expectations with the QB
you've talked yourself into the
throwback Giants bandwagon it can be
2008 again you name it we've got it all
the bells and whistles a strong defense
yeah a franchise quarterback well
okay yeah our cars are gonna break on
you but that's why we gotta next one up
policy that's right we've got seemingly
unlimited options so come on down to the
Niners we'll get there somehow I've got
three words for you no money down right
Lamar I'm not simply it's like it's my
commission yup you didn't support they
want golf hashtag no new fans wag is not
for sale yeah she's got some miles on
her but she's as reliable as always and
don't you ever forget that I really wish
you would stop asking about our safety
features what's up sports fans sure
we're out of it but do you really want
to go oh it's a fancy playoff dealership
or do you want to watch me lift that
sedan
do not I repeat do not come down to
Arrowhead Automotive there's no more
space on our bandwagon that's right our
bandwagon is full and closed because
everyone loves us so much